how's it going dressed my name
welcome well what day oh it's the
Sherry's blue
I mean blue it well it's a matte
collection the fingerprint in the metro
station and the boot print are not the
matchmakers but this other goth so is he
the torturer Buddhist a torch so this
serial killer ex
kills serial killers he takes them down
using their own methods
if the torturer is still at large I say
toxic its implanted in his brain
yeah look at that section what is this
city coming to I done gotta find the
torturer and save his ass
haha that's crazy man
that crazy well I'm no longer an agent
apparently naked pictures well it's too
dangerous for me to come to the bureau
can you meet me at the city Laura don't
and get dyke I don't know alright
tonight now what the hell exactly
there's damage but there's got to be a
terminal or two still chases cars you
guys are talking a lot can you meet me
there in 15 minutes we're gonna see her
real-life Abu [ __ ] cool alright car I
apparently teleported back here I was
like you're standing here but alright
well
well can they add I can't see me all
right what what oh come on dude bad
smell bro do you know what boot to the
face ah boot to the bottom go to the bus
stop hitting me shakes that's right
ha ha Buju power high TV unlock
achievement what I didn't know I could
get done what the [ __ ] was that
oh Jesus dude not cool Jesus not cool at
all [ __ ] yeah so everyone come down come
down come down come boot boot boot boot
boot
that's right boot power Oh what do you
want you want to slam I give you a
xalapa ha ha
I don't know how I did that I mean no
offense I see you man [ __ ] you seriously
boot boot I got your lucky - oh ha it's
mine
ha ha ha ha you can't have it ha ha oh
it's mine now stupid [ __ ] where did
you come from highs that even possible
[ __ ] Locker smack don't sway in
lockers presents boot stupid [ __ ]
everyone hears you [ __ ] crazy man
Jesus cry [ __ ]
what Napoli oh [ __ ] knock your power
what do you want which one do you want
Wow
[ __ ] you dude I'll let you choose and
this is how you repay me
lack of power not another Oh what do you
want
don't [ __ ] boot that was not a bar
everyone here is [ __ ] crazy
god damn man god damn not cool not cool
lucky what do you think about why are
you yelling is he calling me
don't call me now please what no [ __ ]
Sherlock
nothing what are you doing I don't need
to get the hell of everything I have
[ __ ] locker with me oh I clowning
through you better believe it girl
oh that's Tucker girl it's like I want
the yellow locker
it's a beautiful locker you can have the
locker man I can't [ __ ] have it
hey Mike
oh wow I don't mind me I'm just eyes
knocked well what the [ __ ] okay step
aside what am I supposed to go before
you die all right I should problem what
the hell are they doing
what hey this is not my battle man
smack edge smack edge footage smack it
block it back it oh and punch for punch
up matter what your world that's super
loud super loud super lightweight alive
can't do it
shut up hey hey whoa whoa whoa that's
like a million of you okay that's three
but polish whoa that guy's thank you
lucky [ __ ] yeah you got it
ah who's that lady anyway [ __ ] bird
girl what I know I'm dead we're back
nice yellow locker man we can be Locker
blur bras
man you could have been brother Akio my
locker is better than y'all that's right
that's right
oh don't try to laugh at me man you know
what I do to lockers like you I punched
it works in real life you'd be punch
people like that thank you for opening
doors now you and I from a locker tell
the tale to your young children I died
from a locker
Jesus [ __ ] locker
[ __ ] you man you're not supposed to
stand behind me while I try to [ __ ] yeah
Stephanie I just jump down there whoa
Conrad it yeah whoa what are you doing
at my cut you cannot this is not my
blockage blockage stop it ha ha so you
get oh it continues this is [ __ ]
happy wheels man hey push it
Thank You Man ha ha block it block it
chaser edge ha ha ha whoa how's that
[ __ ] Oh No let's go in this way well
hello everyone
Oh stupid blind cops y'all call me now
oh nothing why are you calling me that
cop is so [ __ ] Oh [ __ ] sorry
angry now
all right for every weapon
locker door so that's what it is I was
not lucky doors lucky man lucky is a
lucky light luck that like lot lot I was
good at this before today I was really
good and now they're [ __ ] cutscene
Jesus crisis okay what did they doing
good what the [ __ ]
all right I get the feeling we will meet
the girl now or not maybe more where's
lucky lucky this is not funny man
yeah did they make birth or something
so we're at the library not sure why
it's kind of creepy place man I'm not
gonna lie that's a nice painting I like
its Causse okay I'll add him to the
collection all right president I think
I'm not sure I guess we got to go here
nice nice nicely decorated Oh an
elevator I wonder if we can use it it's
for handicapped people but I think I'll
make an exception for now
it's pretty damn slow elevator I'll tell
you as much come on elevator thank you
all right
which flora will it be basement lovely
you know this elevator really likes
music
yeah whoa dude ha ha no no no no no what
did you do yeah that's my name my mother
rats man yeah get on meth what is wrong
with me
can I just sing Britney Spears ID weird
stuff happening jeez okay alright I
won't lock you back prepare anyone for
that matter is this library at minute oh
I can get going dear kind of laggy I
don't know why in case of fire do not
use elevators don't tell me what to do
with science well [ __ ] hideous look
there now get that girl out of that no
way no I'm not a girl I used my security
okay but no way no way oh [ __ ] but that
check get it off my face oh my god
you're hideous
okay you're not that bad actually you
have the body figure of a man you
dressed like a man too for that matter
haricot is kind of manly too weight is
nothing wrong with dressing but-- do
something oh my god you suck you can't
even spell it right
alright what do you want me to do
alright Ethan Thomas that's me
Jerry Brown's physical they found
several abnormality
I remember hers it put a big suck in my
back it was horrible I know right go to
the face you also have a hyperactive
serotonergic system in the brain
what does I mean looked into my boobs
you don't even have any kind I'm turning
pages jacketed yeah what you'd image I
know if you have one seriously concerned
about is no record all right classified
black Sam it's pretty top level security
way beyond you or me because my
government is awfully interested you see
this I do you see this do you see this
how you do maybe I shouldn't have told
you but there it is
do you see this oh and I also left
something there on the counter for you
too popular modification to the standard
taste no way super taster holy [ __ ] whoa
are you an Android or something
okay you look like you were about to
faint there come on let's get this over
with
what I'm not having something their
hearts to sell are just maniacs
destroying things okay find a terminal
that isn't damaged I agree with you
hello looks like alright I'm alike
surely I have to end as XO d like a baby
did you enjoy subscribe to come bread
today and I'll see you next episode I've
tried to make sales numbers go Tasha I
won I nail it [ __ ] yeah
I became a fountain torso with three
[ __ ] suitors of ketchup that's always
my dream